here we go
next time on 90 day fiance happily ever
after the couples tell all would you
really take myla back to ukraine i don't
think it's healthy for a baby to see
mama being unhappy now long and crying
like i'm dawn i don't know
[Music]
it's gonna lay it all out there
it's
sure then that's what it is
anyone know a good lawyer
if you think you can find better woman
than me and be happy i will only pray
for you honestly
you've been nothing but evil to him are
you joking let's take a break
i don't care i don't give
he has to fall for divorce and we just
bought
[Music]
you better apologize to mom you were the
first one to jump up my mom no that's
why i got up i say no you're not going
to talk to me
don't make me come to you honey please
julia she's become a little hard to live
with her jealous side has come out which
is not normal it's crazy
brandon
we have charlie in the studio today
what are you thinking right now charlie
i'm mad
i got a lot to say so we'll see
hello
she's gonna stay by the hotel with the
cameraman
argue with me tiffany he was jealous
it's not my problem i will make
known
now angela have you only seen dr obang
at the office i also know
i went to his birthday party
oh
you're not his wife are you screwing
them
you are not listening to what she is
you mind your own
wow
[Music]
you